>>Mike: We're two teachers
at the same school.
Both of us teaching two
sections of geometry.
And yet, even in the same school,
the variance can be so wide
at how two people teach
the same lesson.
And so our practice minimizes
that difference in how we teach,
so the kids get a more
equitable, stronger lesson.
I'm Mike, and I teach
Geometry, and Academic Numeracy
at Leadership Public
School of Hayward.
>>Mike: And here's your challenge.
You're going to be silent.
You're going to be right
there in your seats,
and for the next minute-and-a-half,
I want you to think
of at least three solutions
to this equation.
>>And I collaborate regularly
with my co-teacher, Rose.
>>My name is Rose.
I teach Geometry and Pre-Calculus at
Leadership Public Schools in Hayward.
>>So the definition,
all angles are equal.
And more specifically like Aaron
said, they're all 60 degrees,
and that's always going
to be the case.
They're always going
to be 60 degrees.
>>Mike: We're a network
of four schools,
and we're very much all
about trying new ideas.
Succeed at some and fail at others,
with the idea of eventually making
wide-scale change in our communities.
On a daily basis, our goal
with the video camera,
besides general feedback,
is to build a library
to match completely
with the curriculum.
And we'd like full lessons.
And we'd also like to edit
and code by practice or task.
>>Rose: I try more things
when a video camera is
there, than when it's not.
Because when it's not, you
get kind of comfortable
in your every day trend of things.
But when the camera is there,
it forces you to want
to do something extra.
And then you see that extra
thing actually make a difference.
>>Mike: The way we
create that curriculum is
after Rose teaches a lesson, we will
meet, sit down, and for a minimum
of 15 minutes a day
tear apart that lesson.
We'll talk about the pacing.
>>And you got through
this in a timely fashion.
It was really good to see
the pace at which you went
through all -- was it six?
[Rose:] Yeah.
>>Mike: And we'll talk about expected
errors and missed conceptions.
>>And this here would be at
least, I think it was valuable
to take those two minutes.
>>Rose: Yeah, I agree.
This is what they missed, at least.
>>Mike: So in the common
misunderstanding, missed conceptions,
errors section of the teacher notes.
That definitely has to go in there.
>>We'll edit, put sticky notes all
over them so we can make them better.
She'll give me feedback;
I'll give her feedback.
And that's how we continue
to have the curriculum evolve
and make it more precise
and powerful.
>>Rose: Teaching isn't just
about standing up there
and giving them instruction.
It's also about developing yourself,
so that they go to the next level.
>>Mike: Last year, Rose and
I felt this relationship out,
and we got to a point where we felt
comfortable challenging each other.
Sometimes arguing a lot; sometimes
supporting each other a lot.
But all very productive.
>>Rose: We're very open
to going to each other.
And it's because we
have this camaraderie
that took some time to form.
>>Mike: With the benchmarks,
I noticed that my classes were
under-performing her classes
by an average of ten percent.
And so I had to sit down and just
look at that data dispassionately.
And as a competitive
person, that wasn't easy.
I got into her classroom, and
I watched her teach a lesson,
and then I went and tried
to teach the same thing.
And then she would
come in and video me.
Give me feedback.
And this give and take,
back and forth,
eventually helped me
refine my own practice.
I was being a little too verbose.
So I wasn't getting
through the whole lesson.
And I wasn't getting to some
of the higher level tasks
as consistently as she was.
And when she saw this, and I
saw this, I was able to adjust,
make changes, and by the end of the
year, our data was indistinguishable.
>>Rose: In order for any of
us to grow and be better,
which ultimately means student
achievement, we need someone
to tell us, "This is going well,
and this is not going so well.
Here's a potential way to fix it."
>>Mike: It's a reciprocal, positive
relationship, where we both improve
from that feedback, and so this
type of relationship, I think,
is more or less the
secret to our success.